a
[Música]
ah
al principio de este mes la
confederación brasileña de fútbol ha
tomado una decisión histórica a partir
de ahora hombres y mujeres ganarán lo
mismo es una decisión sin precedentes
que pone brasil en la vanguardia del
mundo siguiendo el ejemplo de otras
selecciones como la de australia que
tomó la misma resolución en noviembre
del año pasado a partir de este año
hombres y mujeres jugadores y jugadoras
se recibirán el mismo sueldo y los
mismos premios si es que eso por otra
parte se puede controlar y también hay
que recordar que ya el año pasado
durante el brasilerao se hizo algo
parecido durante la edición del 2019 de
esta forma brasil decide equiparar los
sexos en lo que es el fútbol
[Música]
en eeuu existe una gran diferencia en
materia salarial entre hombres y mujeres
que practican el fútbol de manera
profesional mientras un hombre puede
ganar trescientos mil dólares anuales
una mujer gana cien mil dólares
la otra gran diferencia es que las
mujeres no tienen derecho a
bonificaciones mientras los hombres si
las reciben cuando juegan para un equipo
profesional o para el equipo nacional de
fútbol de los eeuu
esta controversia frente a esta
diferencia en material salarial fue más
evidente después del mundial femenino de
fútbol soccer en 2019 cuando el equipo
de eeuu resultó ganador y esto llegó a
que varios congresistas mujeres pidieran
que se pagaran a las mujeres jugadoras
un salario igual o incluso mayor al de
los hombres
[Música]
la disparidad salarial por género en
portugal sigue siendo tema de debate y
esto no escapa el ámbito deportivo la
polémica más reciente se generó cuando
la federación portuguesa de fútbol le
anunciaba en un reglamento un tope
salarial para las jugadoras de la liga
de fútbol femenino un tope de 550 mil
euros anuales para las inscritas en la
liga bp y sin embargo esto generó
indignación por parte de las jugadoras
puesto que pese a que la federación
explicaba que se trataba de una medida
extraordinaria para afrontar la crisis
generada por la pandemia no se aplicaba
al fútbol masculino inmediatamente lo
consideraron un caso de discriminación
se generó un movimiento entre las
jugadoras que denominaron fútbol sin
género y a los pocos días la federación
tuvo que regular y a través de un
comunicado asegurar que no incluiría
este polémico artículo en el reglamento
correspondiente a 2020 2021 sin embargo
es una realidad que en portugal las
mujeres en promedio ganan menos que los
hombres incluso según datos de la
comisión para la igualdad en el trabajo
y el empleo en líneas generales las
mujeres ganan 17.9 por ciento menos que
los hombres cuando se refiere a un
salario base y 20.8 por ciento menos
cuando
al salario mensual
[Música]